Okay, great, we now have a UI defined
and our Android manifest is almost done.
But because we're using Google Services,
there is one meta tag that we need to
add, and that's just to specify that
we're using the Play Services Library.
We do that like this.
The metadata tag is used
within the application tag and
it should be a sibling of the activity,
not a child.
Within that, your specified Android is
com.google.android.gms.version, and
the value for this is
atInteger/GooglePlayServices_version.
Now as you can see here
it's showing up red.
It's showing up as an error
you cant resolve symbol,
but we're going to fix that in a moment.
And also once that's been fixed, once
your application has been configured to
use these services libraries
whenever you compile,
this will be filled in automatically
with the correct number.
So let's go ahead and do that.
So in order to do that there's one other
place that we need to ensure that we're
using the libraries for the services and
that's in the build.gradle for
the app itself.
So if I go into the build.gradle for
the app,
down here you can see the dependencies
at bottom of build.gradle.
We're going to add a new
dependency in here.
So what we want to add is quite simply,
to compile conduct
google.android.gms:play-services:6.5+.
Now it's important to note that
your version here may be different.
It depends on what you're using, and
what version of Play Services
you've installed.
You can take a look in your system to
see what versions have been installed
for you.
And I'm just using this plus,
just to make life a little bit easier.
I believe I have 6.5.0.87.
But of course, by the time your
watching this Play Services
might be in version 7 or later and as
you can see here, you should avoid using
plus in version numbers because it
can lead to unpredictable behavior.
But I'm just going to leave it in for
the time being, for simplicity.
But do note when you're building your
applications that you should use
the correct version number here.
So now, once we've done this, we're
going to go to our main activity, and
we're going to access
the location provider.
Now, in our main activity, remember that
it contains just a single text view.
When the user runs the app,
we want it to get the current
location using location services, and
write the latitude of the current
location into that text view.
In order to do this, we're going to
need to write some code in the activity.
This code will create
the Google API Client, and
set up the required call backs to catch
responses back from location services.